so more on peter lambert he's just
getting his feet underneath him or was
just getting his feet underneath him as
a big league pitcher when uh he tore his
ucl so he's been out for more than two
years from a big league perspective some
good work in minor league baseball this
year in preparation for this start so
here's la stella as he's going to lead
things off again and listella hitting at
238.
and he drives one to right
hitwell and
out of here he's done it again as he
opens up the game with a home run he did
it friday night and san diego led off
that game with the home run and that
turned out to be a
giant w
let's see what happens tonight that's a
great way to start this game and a rude
way to welcome peter lambert back to the
big leagues yeah it's probably going to
make peter lambert think oh my goodness
oh that's what the big leagues is like
95 inner half 1-0 pitch and lastella
who's known for taking a lot of pitches
as aggressive early in the count gets a
pitch to he likes
and gets it up over that right field
wall and on the mound for the giants
it'll be alex wood 10-4 399 era 128 two
thirds innings pitch
a lot of strikeouts this year not a lot
of walks had a solid year and coming off
the kova dail through three innings in
his last and was dominant very efficient
looking for a little bit more length out
of him tonight
facing charlie blackman now
charlie with a base hit to left brian is
out there tapia beats sent home throw on
its way is cut off
and the rockies tie it up charlie
blackman once again
victimizing alex wood i like what
brendan did and i like what charlie's
done so far they've gone the other way
this is a breaking pitch on the subaru
super bowl and charlie did this in the
dodgers series too against walker
bueller they tried to throw that back
door curveball and he was able to take
it to left field to drive in a run
again
being aggressive two outs here's diaz
and this is popped up to shallow right
stella
drops the baseball and the rockies will
get a run out of it roger scores
blackman to third it'll go down as a
single
in the bermuda triangle tommy listella
got there but he could not squeeze it
vermont way junior was playing deep and
then belt backs off and this is all
tommy la stella
so as he's going out right here he
thinks he's got it and then it goes off
the heel of his glove
that's why he couldn't secure it comes
around rock is up two to one now
crawford winning 298 with 21 big flies
here's the wind up 3-1 pitch
crawford hits a high drive to right
it is out of here and this game is tied
and it didn't come on a 3-0 pitch it
came on a 3-1 pitch now he just got
tuned up on the 3-0 pitch by taking that
swing that locked him right back in he
actually realized how good lambert's
fastball was
says if he gives it to me again i'm not
going to miss it and he didn't that was
loud so crawford with home run number
22. you see the fastball up 106 off the
bat diaz wants it down in the way what
does he do he leaves it belt high right
over the middle part of the plate and
we've seen brandon crawford do this all
year long fastball's middle middle he
doesn't miss him very often so the first
two reach for the giants here in the
third 2-2 game
[Applause]
picks off brandon belt for the second
out of the inning i like the
communication between elias and cj
because as soon as that ball is
delivered cj's already breaking to the
back so all he has to do is wait for
brandon belt to come back in go ahead
and slide right into it thank you very
much
you just seen him fire the baseball all
across the diamond count goes full swung
on it missed so lambert with some help
from diaz
gets out of that inning mikey
is hit towards left
lots of green grass for rhyme el tapia
reaches up makes the catch so alex
dickerson is going to be the pitch
hitter
this is a fly ball to toppy again
dickerson retired
this is
the middle of the diamond and
nicely done
by rogers
giants two rockies two as we move to the
sixth inning from denver and brandon
belt who has hit a fly ball to left
against ashton godeau
belt high and deep to right field way
back there
second deck
and the giants have taken the lead
the 27th home run of the year for belt a
towering
rocky mountain kind of majestic shot to
right and it was a no doubter off the
bat you heard the loud you heard the
noise off the bat it was loud you saw
his reaction he knew he got it at that
point and that was an impressive swing
of the bat this isn't a no two count and
this is a pitch
where brandon belt usually does not get
on top of and what does he do
he gets on top of it hits it 424 feet
out to right field giants have some
action here in the seventh kazrimski is
struck out and he's flied out
high drive
right field blackman bag
out of here mike yastrinsky home run
number 25
and the giants lead six to two well that
wasn't the upper rail that that was
right in mike is stremski's wheelhouse
and that was a two-strike mistake by
ashton goudeau
he wanted to execute it up in the zone
he didn't he yanked it down in the zone
much like we saw longoria's last at-bat
right in the astrinsky's nitro zone and
he didn't miss it to his credit with two
strikes he did not miss this mistake
just barely getting over the wall in
right field
yeah it really doesn't matter how many
park that that's a home run and it's a
home run at coors field it's a home run
at coors field and it's his 25th home
run of the year so here's buster posey
busted an rbi opportunity
shoots this one up the middle of the
base head right past the diving rogers
flores comes in and buster posey with an
rbi single at 7-2 well maybe he guessed
98 down and away it's a good pitcher's
pitch
buster beat it
you see buster when he's really good he
sees that middle part of the field he
barreled that right over the second base
bag
sniffing out rbi
that's a nice swing of the bat right
there brandon crawford who has one of
the homers and has been on base three
times
even with the shift
and now crawford's going to try for two
and he is out at second that's another
outfield assist for blackman this
yalmante salutes the throw by charlie
and i want to give a little
congratulations too to colton welker who
had to make this tag out at second base
but
trevor not there with brendan up there
charlie comes up one hop colton with the
tag goes down and gets him right off did
that hand come off though
and it's you know it's an appropriate
time to take a gamble you're up by five
runs sam holbrook's a crew chief ow ow
love it two down here's story and now
it's a full count three and two
and a high pop fly into shallow right
center in comes duggar he's calling for
it and he's got it and that's the ball
game so game one in this three-game
series it goes to the giants they are at
least gonna stay one game up in the
national league west that's all you can
do is win that game win as many games as
you can between now and the end of the
year and see what happens
you